I
CONSIDER THAT IS A WIN.
HE SAYEVERYTHIITLEFT THE WHITE
VESTIGATION INTO WHAT
AY
WINYG IN PARTICULAR?OUSE
ARE THERE ANY MEMENTO DOCUMEU TK
AN
>> NOTHING OF GREAT Y,E.
OF THOSE.
>> YOU TOOK THOSE
NO, I THINK THAT'S IN THE S IN
ARCHIVES.BUT THE KIM JONG-UN
IN
INCREDIBLE LETTERS WITH OTHER
LEADERS.
KNEW SOMETHING
THERE?NT WAS VERY VAGUE
AND TIT MEAND
PLACE.
MY QUESTION WAS MEMENTO ENNG
DOCUMENTS.
I ASKED THIS ON LA WAS KNOWNVE
S EVERYTHING THEN AS
VOLUNTEERS, MENTIONS THE KIM-U
BACK TRACKS ANNO, ND
BUT WE HAVE GREA
IT WAS NOT CLEAR AT ALL WHAT HE
OUT.
INTERESTING IN HINDSIGHTN
AUGUST 8th WIT FBI SEARCH
OF MAR-A-LAGO.
HIS IMPULSE  NO, NOTHING.
>> THIS IS A CONVERSIO ORMER P
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTID
THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP IN THE LE
SPECIFICALLYUPPORT FROM PRAC
DUKE.SIEGED BOTPUBLIC
I CALLED TRUMP TO TELLIMHE HAD
IM FROM HIS EMACIS
TRUMSUM  HE WOULD TRUMP SSRONG
T MADE K, AAINST HI CABINOFFICA
CALLING HECOA CHOW.
NG TO SEE MOREF
THIS?
>> THE I IT PRETTY .
MORE HE
HE THI
SEEMS LEADING
STATEMENTS.
ALEH OT S
VEIL, IA SAID HAS
A DEATH WISH N
HIBASAY,E
T POTICAL.
THERE IS NO JUSTIFICSOMETHING L
THE  WORDS HAV
SUPPORTERS.
SO IO  WE ARE SEEING
TO OYTHING THAT HE SOR
MEOPEN DURING THFI
TO SEE MH RE2016 AND TN PRESIDEO
>> L I KNOW THE ANSW
T ONHE AIR E GY, B
SA FENT E UNITED STATES -- I SA
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU NC
ARE SA TTHE
PROTHERSAIOU KNOW, I
CAN'T BELIEVE YOU DIDN'T
THIS SOONER.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT HE IRACIST?A
I THINE A SERIES STATEMENTS OVE
PERSONA AND POLITICAA
FODENOW.
INFORMATI I LEARNDURING THE COE
OF REP
E S WHAT YOURS RELATED TO YOUNGA
BI-RACIAL L N THE
ITA CERTAIN POINT HIWILL SAY, N.
W  IME